they are a lifeline to the people
trapped by the fighting
as the sound of war bangs in the
distance alexis safkovic and his
volunteers take essential supplies
wherever they are needed
is there uh
25 30 000 so many really located
but some still stay here
this town of adivca has been fought over
since 2014 and is smacking the path of
putin's army as russia tries to conquer
the dombats
the first drop-off is an elderly man
whose family now live in russian
occupied territory
he is scared and all alone but like many
here is too frail to leave
strewn across the paths there are
fragments of bombs and rockets
the destruction has left this place
without power and running water
but the fighting doesn't stop them
loading the van with more supplies
this is the easton district now
their drive taking them to the edges of
this town
and even nearer the fighting
as more bags are handed over tetiana
tells me what the war has done to
foreign
the delivery team go anywhere and
everywhere despite the danger
their next visit is even closer to the
front line and the handover is
nerve-racking did the shell land
they don't enter this area
it's okay
okay
well there's something coming in then
it's quite close but you can see how
dangerous
these deliveries are but this is on the
outskirts
there are still people here who can't
leave don't want to leave lots of
different reasons but this place is
being shelled continuously but still
they come out
to bring in supplies of food water
and medicine
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
when it feels safer they move from cover
and leave the area
but incredibly the deliveries continue
sometimes when it shells over you and
you can feel some some somewhere closer
uh yeah there are some feeling when you
need to to lie not to
to keep your head down yeah yeah and
then the delivery stops for that day and
you try again another day no we you try
one area yeah we wait we wait until when
this end it's okay it's safer and
continue
on the last stop we meet valentina and
her six grandchildren
in their childhood innocence they seem
every week civilians here are killed in
the fighting
alexi and his team know their work is
dangerous
but so too is living on the front line
and without him the suffering for many
of these people would be even worse
alex rossi sky news eastern ukraine